but he says so many people came to me
and told me the things that my dad did
for them that I never knew about
he said the most emotional thing for me
was how many men came and said do you
really know who your dad was do you
really know who your dad was he says my
dad never bragged about what he did for
other people but everybody could come in
there's nothing like when I go around
other men that have known my dad for a
while and they tell me what my dad did
for them there's nothing like it there's
nothing like it at the end of the day
that's what it's going to come down to
at your funeral either they're gonna say
this guy smashed so many he made a lot
of money or freaking a this guy changed
our life and especially so many that no
one knows about it's by far the best
stories when people say things like that
so